[Music]
I got to hold down the
city got to let you know where I
come I got to hold down the city got to
let you
know I got to hold down the city got to
let you know
on my laps in the gym the sweat ran off
my skin they thought I ran out of breath
but I was just catching my win that only
happens to them I got to capture my win
I practice 31 days a month and I
practice again was born a quit with
sportsmanship so watch just laugh and I
grin Victory is my objective I don't
have to pretend spread my wings like a
eagle and let them flap in the wind no G
no glory no pain no gain these are
actions of men my teammate is a warrior
got my back to the end my offense is God
sent you going to have to defend my
crossover is vicious I got more Swagger
than him hit the bottom of the net or
the back of the rim your sty is a flavor
foul your score I'mma take it down all
of your trash talking was pointless say
it now you slacking and gold ending my
AC a bone chilling got the home court
advantage I'm back on the road win
it I got to hold down to
city let where I
come I got to hold down the
city
let I got to hold down the city
got to let you know where I come from I
got to hold down the city got to
let I got to hold down the
city let where I
come I got to hold down the
city let
know I got to hold down the C